okay second go can you not screw it up
this time so things are moving forward
with the next full installment of the
x-men franchise obviously we've had a
lot of movements lately on the spin-offs
we've had some news about Deadpool -
there's been some word on New Mutants
but this is the confirmation of a big
chunk of the cast for x-men Dark Phoenix
now sort of the big news in this because
it seemed very up in the air is the
retention of James McAvoy as Professor
Xavier Michael Fassbender as magneto and
Jennifer Lawrence as mystique also
returning will be nicholas hoult at
beast Alexandra Shipp as storm sophie
Turner as Jean Grey ty Sheridan as
Cyclops and Kodi smit-mcphee at
Nightcrawler notably absent from that
list is Evan Peters as Quicksilver that
does not necessarily mean that he won't
appear but at this point it's looking
unlikely because the thing is supposed
to start shooting next month so maybe
they just realized that they had made
him so powerful just to make that scene
in Days of Future past awesome that
really he kind of breaks the narrative
additionally not yet signed McCarthy in
talks is Jessica Chastain who is in line
to play the Shiar Empress which that is
a big deal because it means that
basically all of the space stuff that
got yanked out of the story when it was
adapted as part of x-men the left hand
is being put right back in this all
sounds like pretty good news doesn't it
so you're probably wondering what's with
the title of this video well I'll
explain the Dark Phoenix saga is not a
small story it is pretty significant
especially for the time that it was
written and given that Chris Claremont
has a tendency to over write these are
packed pages there's a lot of story
trying to adapt it straight the film is
really a difficult prospect I'm not
going to say it's impossible but I am
going to say they are going to
completely screw it up because what this
thing needs to hinge on what this story
has to hinge on is not the nuts and
bolts like I'm not saying it must be
exactly like what's in the calm
but what needs to be retained is the
heart of it which is gene going bad and
having that means something and its
impact on the team there's a big problem
with that because this will only be the
second thing we've gotten with sophie
Turner as Jean Grey and you know what
she didn't get a heck of a lot to do
other than at dark Phoenix last time
around and I can't imagine that they're
going to be able to cram in enough
building of her and her dynamic with the
team to have it mean anything when she
goes bad in Dark Phoenix especially
considering they already botched the set
up because the whole thing the reason
Dark Phoenix was a huge deal besides
just how nuts it is is the fact that
Jean Grey was really the most boring
character on the team she was the good
girl so when she just went and
completely turned on the team became a
threat to the whole galaxy whoa that was
a big deal
instead when they introduced her in
x-men apocalypse she's already kind of
being isolated and looked at like she's
not gelling with the group so already
there they screwed up the initial
dynamic that is supposed to be in place
my big concern about this though is the
fact that they have brought back McAvoy
Fassbender Lawrence now I don't think
they're bad Act well I don't think
Jennifer Lawrence is a bad actress but I
actually think she's quite good and a
lot of things but she just looked really
bored in Apocalypse I did not want them
to bring her back she doesn't seem to
want to be here maybe it'll turn around
she was fine in first class in any case
they should not be bringing all three of
those back because they haven't been
able to get the story off of them since
first class really they put the focus
primarily on those three you know and
Wolverine in Days of Future past and you
know what for those stories that was
fine well not for apocalypse nothing was
fine about apocalypse but I got it why
they were doing it for those ones this
one the story has to be on Jean and on
these other characters and if they're
going to put in Magneto Professor X and
mystique magneto mystique who have never
had a part in this story before to try
and work them in the more time they gets
put on them and you know it's going to
be put on them because they're
to be the big drawers and they are the
biggest name actors and characters in it
then the less time is going to be put
all the stuff that needs to be built
properly because it hasn't been built in
the movies leading up to this magneto
absolutely should not be here he should
not be this kind of distraction because
that's all he's gonna be and he should
not be so kept time I like Michael
Fassbender his role a lot he should not
be here
and then despite what I just said about
Jennifer Lawrence mystique I will give a
pass too because they did kind of set
her up as basically like the team leader
so okay she was an integrated part of
the team I was prepared to roll with
that but there they should not have
brought back all three really the only
one that they desperately should have
been trying to get back with James
McAvoy the other two they should have
just let go
Lawrence maybe but Fassbender should not
be coming back and again it just shows
that the priorities are all screwed up
if they're going to try and tell the
story again and their focus is all wrong
now as far as the whole idea bringing
the Shiar Empress into this which means
bringing in the outer space stuff and
all that stuff on the one hand the
positive to that is it makes it very
easy to distinguish it from the last
time they try to adapt it which was all
very grounded but part of the reason it
was much more grounded in the last end
was because the way that the x-men
universe has been built up to this point
it doesn't really accommodate the insane
outer space stuff that got used in this
story and has been a part of x-men lore
but the movies have never dealt with it
so to throw it in there in a story that
goes whole hog on it that's that's all
hard needle to thread that could
potentially just be really jarring and
eye rolling and I know audiences are
capable of swallowing the cosmic stuff
but when you have what is tangible
however many movies now that establish
this is a semi grounded earth based
franchise to suddenly introduce
basically guardians of the galaxy type
stuff into that that is going to be a
hard pill to swallow at this point I
think the ships already sailed for what
they've established x-men as being as
far as how it is as a friend
Chai's apocalypse was their chance to
sort of bridge that gap except they
didn't go as bonkers with that as they
could have because that's what would
have allowed us to sort of get to the
more hyper real reality that would allow
for the alien stuff but they didn't take
it that far it actually maybe it
wouldn't matter to even if they did
because not that many people like the
apocalypse anyways look the last and
screwed up this story but the way that
it screwed up the story was by making it
the B plot after it had been set up it
should have been the a plot there are
aspects of that film that still works
largely because we had already been with
Jean Grey Monica Jensen's Jean Grey for
two movies already we were invested in
her simply by her presence we don't have
that kind of built-in investment into
sophie turner especially since she
hasn't really felt like getting like
they haven't felt like a team you can't
just reform the team next film we break
up the teeth you have to have a middle
film where they just function as a team
this is why the age of Ultron Avengers
movie was important to have even though
it was a lesser film you couldn't get to
Civil War unless you have something like
Avengers age of Ultron first because you
bring the team together with Avengers
you have to show them basically together
functioning as dean yet but still that
little things maybe they're not perfect
but you just show them this is how they
are this is what the stakes are this is
what is getting lost when the team then
splits and breaks apart and tears itself
apart of the seams if we don't have that
metal film to truly appreciate what it
is that they are when they are together
and functioning then we don't appreciate
the loss of it because so Jeanne
becoming the Phoenix the dark Phoenix
tears the team apart it's a it is a
fundamental betrayal and it makes them
question what do we do but the
investment of that is gone because we
haven't had we're not going to have had
a film of them just being the team just
being the x-men I think ultimately that
was a big part of my problem with my a
ton of problems with Apocalypse but that
was a big one in a lot of ways like it
does we don't really have
x-men we have Magneto
and we have mystique and we have Charles
and apocalypses in there the other state
feel two backgrounds they don't feel
like here's the team it feels like
here's our cast and here's the
supporting cast and it of itself that's
not the end of the world unless you do a
story that really depends on us being
invested in those more background
characters which this story done and I'm
not converted at all by the fact that so
far as I can tell Simon Kinberg is still
attached to the director Simon Kinberg
has been a producer on the x-men for a
long time that highs and lows so I'm not
going to say he's a bad thing for the
franchise but he's never directed a film
before you're going to try and tackle
this are you not I mean
basically they're starting from zero
because you know these characters these
new younger x-men like we had so little
investment in most of them I leaked I
thought I didn't care I think the only
ones I liked that all were I mean I like
the beasts already because he's been
around a little bit but I liked storm
and I liked Nightcrawler but I think
honestly that is more to do with the
fact that I like those characters I
didn't feel like they can please screw
them up but it didn't care about gene I
didn't like Cyclops at all and they need
to be the heart of this story because
he's in love with her so this investment
in of her is part of how we feel the
pain of that loss but I didn't like her
and I really didn't like him I don't
know how other people were but I don't
remember anybody raving about either of
those two Moreau apocalypse there is so
much ground that needs to be regained in
this movie that's going to try and tell
the story and again I'm not going to say
it's impossible but I don't see it
happening I think it is going to suck a
lot I think
x-men the main franchise is going to die
and it's going to live off of spin-offs
it's got to live off of Deadpool maybe
New Mutants depending on how that hits
but this main series I think this is
going to suck and I think there's a
decent chance it will underperform if
people get the whip of apocalypse about
it so those are my thoughts on
sort of where my brain went after the
casting confirmations for x-men Dark
Phoenix what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down on
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter and council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher you can
also listen to me as one half of the
points either girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]